would you want to hang out with Antonio
Brown and if so what would you talk
about I don't know I I would have to
bring an interpreter I think with Mead
in looking at some of his tweets I I
just I don't understand I mean I'm not
hip enough for young enough to
understand some of the lingo but boy
it's hard to hard to interpret what he
is saying on Twitter right now okay but
how did we get here well the new coach
in Denver I'm trying to remember his
name I came from from Chicago been a fan
geo he had a quote about death by inches
and how if you give a little bit you
can't keep giving a little bit that that
those inches will turn into you know
yards what your mother used to tell you
don't I give you an inch don't take a
yard well that's what happened with
Antonio Brown I do believe they kept
giving in to his little whims and this
that the other thing and I think it got
out of hand I think he thought he was
bigger than the team do you and I'm also
trying to figure this out I talked to an
NFL scout last night I said what is he
worth and he said you know you're
probably if you're lucky get a fourth
round pick for him even though he's you
know he's turning 31 he's been
unbelievable the last six years but you
know you have to have that ratio of how
much baggage and how much talent and
what is your age and all those things
factored in there but is is Antoni is is
brown on the team next year with the
Steelers I don't think so Dan I think
he's reached the point of no return now
he's supposed to have this meeting with
art Bernie the team president sometime
this week but in the meantime he's been
tweeting stuff about Ben and stuff about
Mike Tom and I just don't know how they
they go back and put that back in the
bottle and start over again
maybe they can I don't know you know
where stuff has happened but I just
don't see it I really don't if you could
say to this Steeler fan base you can
have levy on bail back or Antonio Brown
back
yeah I think it went Brown I really do
really they have James Connor here now
he made the Pro Bowl last year I think
they're going to rededicate to their
running game because they were they
pretty much abandoned it last year and
the kids still made the Pro Bowl I think
they're definitely ready to move on
they're both the team and their fandom
but you know there's still still some
fans out there who and Antonio Brown has
done a lot for the organization through
the years helped them win a lot of games
and a lot of people remember that and I
and I think that's why our Ernie want to
sit down with him just to find out what
the heck is going on because this has
always been one of those model
franchises but you know here we are with
they're just drama and I said that we're
gonna look back on this era of what
could have been with the Steelers and I
said that two years ago that I thought
talent-wise
they were talented as anybody far more
talented than the Patriots but that
drama element Edie it's you you know you
can't quantify it but it's still there
it's always felt like it was there and I
don't know how much blame you put on
Mike Tomlin but Mike Tomlin's the head
coach and I just don't know if Bill
Cowher handles it differently and maybe
that's not fair to compare the two but
those are the you know last two coaches
for this team would have been different
with Bill Cowher coaching this team than
Mike Tomlin yeah you sound like some of
the fans in Pittsburgh group you know
say the same thing there was a lot of
drama with bill too I mean it really was
I don't want to go all over it right now
but there definitely was a lot of drama
with him you know it's just it's not the
coach it wasn't still it was just stuff
happens I mean you know we'd go over the
drama here the the national anthem thing
they botched the coach didn't have
anything to do with that
losing Ryan shazier lady on bells
contract stuff I don't know that Tomlin
was to blame for that you know and all
different kinds of stuff martavis Bryant
and the drug stuff and you know him
wanting to be traded which was a
joke but then they got a third when you
were saying a fourth round pick for
Antonio Braun I'm starting to I'm
thinking wow they got a well maybe maybe
John Bruno give me a first round pick
Fran Tonio brown maybe yours thought
that they could get a first round pick
I'm not so sure that he won't buckle
down let's say they do trade them and be
a good citizen on his next job because
he's gonna want to prove everybody in
Pittsburgh wrong do you think he became
a celebrity Edie where he was a
feel-good story surprised everybody and
then all of a sudden now you're
different or you think you're different
yeah it's hard for me to put my finger
on it but he was he was it was a good
teammate and his teammates love them a
lot of them still do but then he started
pulling like basically shenanigans you
know he would he would before they put
the rule in it you could celebrate he
did these stupid excessive celebrations
and got fine and got 15-yard penalty and
they tried to control that and he threw
fits on the sidelines he did that
Facebook live thing after playoff win in
Kansas City while Mike Tomlin was
addressing the team but then things
things turned different this year Dan
they really did you know there was some
some some different acts not not all of
them involving the football team yeah
and that's the thing you had the
speeding ticket you had some kind of
altercation with a woman in his you know
in Florida so I don't know alleged
furniture throwing off the 14th floor
balcony in Florida you know a lot of
stuff yeah I mean he left the team three
times once for a week in training camp
but they covered up they said he had an
injury and he really didn't once on a
Monday after the Kansas after they lost
to Kansas City and he he threw a fit on
the sideline didn't show up Monday and
then them at the end of the season
I mean acquit on yeah but if he leaves
it makes your job a little tougher no it
doesn't really because I don't I don't
have much interaction with him he
he talks Fridays and that's my day off
Dan you know after games there's so many
people to talk to I mean the stories are
always there I know what you're saying
yeah there's always somebody else around
the corner
well you've been doing this for a long
time since 1985 so I'm sure that you'll
have something else to write about next
season with the Steelers Edie thank you
as always for joining us all right
thanks for having me on dan said Busha
he covers the Steelers Pittsburgh
post-gazette for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]